good afternoon Melanie how are you
Abhinav knowin Melanie vaquita steer me
agita sport you get a deer well how is
it me friends sorry Melanie say that
again
Melanie Zack does nochmal you get the
sport ticket I am well how are you doing
very well thank you
I'm here at the worldwide partner
conference with 16,000 partners on our
CEO on the big stage so no pressure
good
dunker he's been here Abbeville fighter
partner conference mid 16000 Palmas of
their goals and una Azul kind walk have
to debate Meister shocked to be have
seen the World Cup
yes I did see the World Cup
congratulations
yeah II saw David Cup Gluckman sure he
can take a nice look you survived kappa
d can turn off the fire I could not be
happier I celebrated the whole night in
item I'm second year at Deutschland
Liacouras austin england indeed lips
inspire and style and Susanna
the single game Germany has scored more
goals in England in the last two events
together
very funny Melanie I'm more of a cricket
fan z follow me Lonnie ein click 'add
Finn the vegan let's master nap defense
title what are you doing after the event
this afternoon I fly back to Seattle
then on Thursday I fly to New York
followed by Miami then back to Seattle
and at the end of July I'm gonna fly to
the UK to see my friends and family in
London
Hoyt enough me tag Ashley Gazoo ignosi
ADA aunt Anne I'm Donna stack a flagon
of New York effect for Miami on danse
avec la clé on a meander you leave le
flic Marcos Bellet onion on mine a
finder unfamiliar in London Susan wow
that sounds like a packed calendar hope
that either good journey
thanks Melanie goodbye danke me Lana
Vida zein dank ADEA sure knock knock
thank you so much thank you you didn't
[Applause]
each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
[Music]